[Music]
congratulations on your work with the
Olympics I thought you did an amazing
job
thank you I don't know how many people
watched that thing I'm guessing it's not
hundred and eleven hundreds of thousands
of people and but but it's a big
responsibility to be the face of the
Olympics you did a terrific job
were you pleased with how it all turned
out well there are always little
quibbles but I thought we were doing
well headed to the finish line yeah and
we get right to the end of the closing
ceremony they extinguished the flame and
the final act in a closing ceremony that
had iconic British pop acts the final
act is the who yeah huge and NBC decides
that at that moment they should provide
America with a sneak preview of animal
practice and then come back an hour
later and have the whole check in on the
hill check in on the who so so what's
animal practice what is that general
practice is evidently a comedy at least
we're hoping it is that that revolves
around a veterinary practice and one of
the doctors is a chimpanzee so a monkey
Oh a monkey it's a monkey thats right
now to give back it's a monkey right so
so here so here is the balance that NBC
has to consider the who animal practice
right Roger Daltrey Pete Townsend monkey
in a lab coat get on I'm sure you'd be
the first to a test Conan that when it
comes to the tough calls NBC usually
gets them right
[Applause]
you're the best guests ever